shaq
okay what is he thinking about
oh i have a really sick idea folks
i think i have a really sick idea
does anybody see what i'm intending
after king h1
if you've done you know
your share of tactics you should be
aware this is a
an idea that is not uncommon
[Music]
let's go
abhid
lover
i do want to play very aggressively so
let's play sicilian
now let's play night or i mean the night
or
is my sort of childhood opening
it is the sicilian that i know best
okay and never mind we're not playing
the night north white is playing the
anti-climactic delayed allopin
okay so knight f6 is the move here
and e5 which
i have seen
this move before
i know it's not good i know for a fact
it's not good now
i think by deduction it should be clear
that we take on e5 now how should we
how should we proceed here well
i suppose that the most annoying thing
about this position is that white has
this knight on e5 and that knight could
be used
as a
starting point for a rather annoying
attack on the f7 pawn
so my first inclination is to
try to get rid of this knight
as quickly as we can but but in a very
efficient way
if we play for example queen c7 then we
allow white to play d4 and support the
knight with the pawn so the best way to
do it is with another knight
so we go knight bd7 a move that i think
a lot of people would resist just
because it looks a little bit awkward
but if you know why you're playing this
move then
it shouldn't look
awkward at all it should be
totally understandable
okay knight takes d7 now if we're
recapturing we might as well develop a
piece so let's recapture with the bishop
and then the bishop from d7 could swing
on over to c6
occupying the long diagonal
now this is very this is a very bad
opening for white
white is just struggling for equality
now
bishop c4
get bishop c4 so
the way that i the way i see it we have
two priorities in this position the
first is indeed to improve the position
of the bishop on d7 which is quite
awkwardly placed we should probably
consider putting it on c6 as i explained
earlier yeah we could play b5 and chase
the bishop away but we also want to be
careful about not biting off more than
we can chew on the queen side if we just
start shoving our pawns down the board
indiscriminately white's gonna start
you know cutting away
at our pawn chain
so i don't particularly love b5 and the
second priority is to complete the
development of our king side and the way
that i i think we should do that is by
playing the move e6 right because the
bishop is on c4 so e6 would serve the
purpose of
causing the bishop to bite on granite
that's why i don't think we should go g6
i think we should specifically go e6 and
then bishop e7 in castles now in what
order should we do
the two things well i think it makes
sense to play bishop c6 first because
this attacks the g2 pawn and it
essentially forces white's hand
white is
basically forced to castle
and now we complete our development with
e6 or prepare to complete it
the other positive byproduct to playing
bishop c6 first is that if white plays
d4 which is not unlikely and we play c
takes d4 and if the bishop had still
been on d7 white would have been able to
take back with the queen and keep his
pawn structure intact knight a3
okay well it's clear to me that white is
trying to get the knight in via b5 maybe
i mean we could just not
yeah let's just play
well actually no
because i actually think that white
might want to go knight c2 here
it's it's not trivial what we should do
here it's it's far from trivial
okay
let's play a6 let's prevent
let's prevent knight p5 and but mainly i
wanted to prevent bishop b5 okay bishop
b3
yeah very very strange play i guess
he's
opening up the c4 score for the night
but i'm not entirely sure why that's
dangerous
um we could play b5 here and continue to
restrict white's minor pieces in fact i
think b5 here
is quite a good move
yeah i like b5 a lot because i think
what it does is it
i mean look at how how much it restricts
all of white's pieces and it also
prepare okay knight c2
okay amazingly this does not blunder a
piece
amazingly this does not blunder a piece
because after c4 there's this move
knight d4
there's this move knight d4
counter-attacking the bishop on c6
ridiculous i don't think white even saw
this
okay so
i think a different approach is required
here
i think i know what we should do
i think we should set up a great gift
sacrifice
i think we should play bishop d6 let's
not forget that our second priority was
at one point to complete the development
of our pieces we haven't done that yet
so again i mentioned this last time when
in doubt you need to default to things
that are reasonable right bishop d6 you
know is a reasonable move because it
develops the bishop it aims the bishop
at h2 the other bishops aimed at g2c4
okay and now
i can kind of just sense
that
we are on the cusp of winning the game
via some sort of a tactic now you might
say wait a second
what about the greek gift sacrifice
bishop takes h2 king takes h2 knight g4
check
but wait a second the queen on on d1
controls the g4 square so that doesn't
mean we abandon the idea can we set up
the greek gift sacrifice here this is a
classic movie you should all be aware of
it
if you haven't castled yet
yeah the move h5
can be
tremendously effective
because it
anchors the g4 square not only does it
prepare the greek of sacrifice it also
prepares straight up the move knight g4
he plays d4
okay this is interesting
so if we play bishop takes h2 king takes
h2 knight g4 white i think is intending
king g3
and i'm not entirely convinced that we
have
sufficient uh
firepower there
to continue the attack
let me think
we're just playing
very badly but it's very for some reason
very hard to play against the way he's
playing and i don't really understand
why
i'm calculating the gree gift i'm
calculating it
okay let's do it no let's not let's
unless that
i kind of want to go knight g4 also
okay
i have a compromise
let's play bc
let's play bc
and now let's go knight g4 and now let's
go to h4 and i'll explain i use h3
though
yeah i'm getting outplayed a little bit
here
okay
well not really outplayed per se just
position remains complicated i guess
okay let's go queen c7
okay i have an idea
okay what is he thinking about
oh i have a really sick idea folks
i think i have a really sick idea
does anybody see what i'm intending
after king h1
if you've done
you know
your share of of tactics you should be
aware this is a
an idea that is not uncommon
bishop bishop g1 yeah bishop g1
bishop g1
and the point is that you're threatening
the mate on h2
but you're doing it from two different
sources yeah knight takes g4
i saw this and now i thought h takes g4
and if he takes the bishop bunchy one
then we play g takes h3 and i did not
see a way for white to defend against
mate
i'm sure such a way exists you will
probably find it but let's see because
we played she takes h3 if white plays g3
then we checkmate with h2
if white
plays something else then we play h
takes g2
and i just didn't see a move here for
white i guess there is d5 but
then we can still take on g2 and then go
queen h2 check i mean
that has to be good for black just has
to be
so i actually think this is
good for us although
it's complicated
it's really complicated d5 played
okay so hg
yeah this is gonna take a lot of uh
precision here for me to win this
i i think i know what to do though
so what is the purpose of h takes g2
well obviously we should give a check
here that is not up to debate right that
is that is obvious
now after king f3
we have several ways to continue the
attack
we have several ways to continue the
attack one of the ways is to say okay
which pieces are not participating in
the attack and i'm accelerating this i'm
you know i'm not going to spend much
time on this because i got to move rook
d8 rook d8 is a typical typical kind of
thought such positions but i think i
have a better idea what i think we're
going to do
is throw in another check on h3 this
seems counterproductive
you should be looking at this at this
moment thing i don't really get why we
would help the king move to h2 but e2
but the idea is he takes d5
and the reason
that we have lured that we have lured
his king to e2
is what who can tell me what the idea
actually is
well no bishop takes d5
there's bishop b5 check that's exactly
right
the bishop on c4 is now stuck
and he goes back to d3 it's a really
good move
now
i'm saying okay i think it's critically
important for us to activate the rook on
a8 but if we go king d7 we walk into a
fork bishop f5 check so let's play the
move king f8 which accomplishes two
things it tucks the king away
on a much safer square a
and b
it prepares to get the rook into the
game via e8
yeah long castle would also walk into
bishop f5 check now i'm 100 sure that
i'm not playing this ideally but
i think i'm making decent moves
what if king d2 yeah i think white has
to play king d2 i don't see another move
and then
well we could still play rookie eight
you know we
nobody canceled
the idea of getting the rook into the
game anyway right rook on the e8 is just
a good piece period
right even if it's not quote unquote
doing anything
right but that's a very misleading
concept right this concept of oh this
piece isn't doing anything
well it it's on an open file right it's
just like
a good piece
and it's it's very okay king c2 what
should we do now
so what i'm seeing here and you perhaps
you also see this is that bishop a4
check is an incredibly tempting move
which is
ineffective and effective on account of
b3 but but
we can start with the move c4 right the
moment you see that it should be easy
and now bishop a4 check
and now i think we're in good shape
yeah now we're winning
now we're winning
so b3
we could even play rook takes b3
that should be winning as well but i
think seat well let me think cb
king b2
queen e5 king a3
b2
king takes a form okay three queen c3
queen yeah winning okay
i think it's winning
let's take
king b1 okay that makes it easy for us
though
just
take
goodbye queen
good bye queen
no but it's a free queen but
there was nothing that white could have
done
there was absolutely nothing that white
could have done it turns into a quite a
good game i think
but i'm i'm very unhappy with the way
that i was attacking
something about the way that i will
check bishop g one of the engine
if it was correct then
we'll say that my play was somewhat
justified if not
then shame on me
okay so how should we actually win this
what should we do in a position like
this because it's important here not to
rest on your laurels
and not to just sort of slink away and
lose the game on time like let's say you
have a minute here well you need to say
all right i've got the b file and that's
my main vehicle
toward white's king
so you might as well go rook b3 check as
that rook was already hanging so you
might as well move it
and if king a1 it's very important to
notice queen e5 check picks up the
bishop on f5
rook b2
that's a good move i mean white's doing
everything he can to defend this what
should we do now well now we have a
choice we can simplify i think
in the
given the time situation the most
prudent option is to simplify
and what should we do now
again let's say you've got 50 seconds
you're trying to win this you're trying
to avoid losing on time
yeah you could play rook c8 guys but
you're not
no no no nobody has said it yet rookie
one if you want to play like a russian
school boy go rookie one trade rooks if
you've identified a
winning strategy then follow through
with it
okay rook c1 we don't even have to take
that immediately
if we don't want to we could just start
oh actually no we should we should
we should we actually should
and now it's over okay so i would even
just start pushing
i would even start pushing
and we've got plenty of squares for our
king he'll probably throw in a check on
a3 but
it's not going to do anything
notice that if white puts the bishop
anywhere it'll be forked bishop b523
check
okay
and he resigns
very good
yeah
nice game
overall
strange game very very strange strange
strange play by white i mean i'm not
used to 1900s playing like this
yeah so this was the delayed alpine
normal start
now you might uh
you know if you're a sicilian player
you might be aware that bishop e2 here
is considered the traditional main line
and you should know that knight takes e4
is a common trap
the queen forks the knight of the king
so the main line if i'm not mistaken
here is actually this weird looking move
bishop d7 but if you i mean the point is
to reinforce the threat of knight take
c4
and to cover the a4 square
okay you can investigate this there's a
bunch of theory here
yeah e5d e95
i'm seeing quite a few games in the
database and knight bd7 is the most
popular move so i think this is correct
there was a question
why not knight c6
and i can point to two reasons
the first is that after knight c6 bc why
why uh damage your pawn structure right
it's not the end of the world but why
allow it the second reason is after
bishop b5 the knight is under a lot of
pressure
and paradoxically even though it's not
protected by a pawn on d7 it's protected
by a bunch of pieces and so bishop b5
simply does not come with the same
effect it doesn't threaten anything
you can eat
by a6 you can play
a6
whereas if you compare knight c6 bishop
b5 a6 there's knight takes c6
right so
important distinction there takes takes
black is already slightly better no
doubt about it we're up development this
pawn on c3 is neither here nor there
and white continues to play strangely
bishop c4
bishop c6
castles we play e6 so here we're playing
normal moves
knight a3 white continues to play
strange moves i would have probably
played d4 if i were white a while ago
but obviously
i mean this is like a dream iqb setup
for black
look at the control the black has on the
square in front of the pawn i mean this
is like
freaking karpov would slay eight dragons
for a position like this
you know you gotta slay the dragon and
you clean your room you know and and and
and you know
you gotta bear you know bear the
responsibility you know and and and
soldier nitsan yeah so after bishop c4
uh bishop c6 castles
e6
knight a3
yeah a6
a6 a6 because i because i was
just irritated at the prospect of white
trading light squad bishops
the actual reason i played it yeah so
just to be very clear after bishop d6
the reason i played a6 is not not
not knight b5 why not can somebody
explain this to me this is the kind of
move that a lot of people at like a 14
1500 level
would fear but in fact it's it's an
empty thread it's a paper tiger because
the bishop drops back to b8 now the
bishop is more than happy
uh to sit around on b8 it doesn't matter
the distance between the bishop and the
pawn it's doing the same thing
on the next move we're going to play a6
and toss the knight back around to a3
you shouldn't be afraid of moves like
that what i was worried about is bishop
e5
you might say well i don't understand
can't black just take on b5 and then do
the same thing
yes
but the reason i was scared of bishop b5
is more positional than tattoo i wanted
to keep the bishop alive because i felt
like the bishop on c6 is sort of the
anchor of black's position it's aiming
at g2 i didn't want to give away the
piece that easy
so a6 is more positionally prophylactic
than anything bishop b3
i was expecting knight c2 here to
prepare d4
but no white continues shuffling back
and forth
and now b5 expanding
knight c2
so this moment unsettled me a little bit
and i think my
subsequent reaction was non-objective
yeah at first i thought c4 wins the
bishop but unfortunately there's knight
d4
maybe black is a winning move here but i
don't see it
i mean cb knight c6 and the knight
returns
if you desperado on g2 i know some
people are thinking i can do this
but y just takes and then takes
material is still equal
queen f3 is coming the king is quite
safe on g2
paul
oates says i don't get it what uh what
exactly
uh don't you get can you can you state
your question
yeah and the reason that white saves the
bishop is if you say well okay i'm gonna
play bishop b7 then bishop c2
and uh
if black plays queen d5 and says ah i'm
going to give you a mate threat i'm
going to force you to defend against
that and then i'm going to take your
bishop well no white can take the bishop
and simultaneously defend against the
mate threat
man rod says couldn't you sacrifice
bishop which is due to one of them well
that's what i just explained right
yeah very good what about e5 first well
e5 is is too uh long of a wind up
right e5 yes it threatens c4 but
this is too long of a wind up i could
even play rookie one and threaten this
pawn with check
or i could play d3 and prevent c4
okay
so we played bishop d6 black white plays
c4 another weird move sorry
another weird move but surprisingly
effective
and i understand the point like d4 now
there is c4 winning the bishop
so c4
and i think at this point i i played
somewhat unobjectively
i just could not resist the urge to play
h5 and hopefully you can't blame me for
that the greek gift looks incredibly
incredibly powerful here
another idea that you should be aware of
is the so-called double bishop sacrifice
so
i'm going to make two
comparisons to detours the first is to
the concept of the double bishop
sacrifice whenever you see two bishops
aimed at the ancient g pawns like that
in certain situations both bishops can
be sacrificed in order to open up the
opposing side's king
this is not one of those situations okay
so
this is not one of those situations
and
you know i could delve into the reason
behind that but instead i'll just show
you the stem game of this bishop
sacrifice not the only game far from the
only game that features a double bishop
sacrifice but
definitely the most famous one i know
some people in the chat are
already pointing it out it's the alaska
bauer game
one of the more famous games of all time
but still still there's there's quite a
few people who don't know it so
yeah 1889
so
this is the position on the board lasker
plays knight h5
lasker plays knight h5 and black takes
on h5 and bauer probably says okay well
you're gonna play queen takes h5 and i'm
gonna play f5
and i'm gonna shut down
shut down the bishop on d3 and then i'm
gonna shut down the other bishop by
playing bishop f6 no harm no foul
does anybody remember what laska played
here
so he starts with bishop takes h7 check
sacrificing the bishop
this drives the king out to h7 he takes
on h5 with check the king moves back to
g8
now i feel like some of you probably in
this position are thinking wait a minute
might i be able to go rook f3
the problem with this is that black can
play f6
and
if you think about it rook h3 doesn't
really threaten
all that much
because let's skip a move
at best you're going to get a perpetual
check black's king is always going to
have this escape route to e8
so at the very best you're going to have
a perpetual
but lasker sacrifices his second bishop
on g7
this threatens checkmate on h8 so the
king must capture
now a check on g4 very important
forcing the king onto the h file because
this is checkmate
and finally the rook lifts up to f3
and still the game is not over bauer
finds a brilliant defense
the mate threat is rook h3 does anybody
see
how black can prolong the game here
why queen g4 instead of just rook f3
first i'll explain that in a moment
so bishop h4 doesn't actually help you
can just take on h4
and then
just like first of all this is just
checkmate so it's a mood point e5 very
good
rook h3 check queen h6
and in the end black seems to be none
the worst for wear i mean black has two
bishops in a rook for the queen but as
often happens in these combinations
like at the end of these combinations
you often have a fork that's just a
common pattern
and boom goes to dynamite queen d7 and
lasker wins this wins the peace one of
the bishops and wins the game
that concludes the combination so that
is known as the double bishop sacrifice
i even had an article on this
takes takes
paul asked a very good question why not
rook f3 first why not rook f3 here
good question
um
the reason is because of rook g8
and the king is able to run away through
f8 through e8 and then through d7 and
remember that you had sacrificed two
bishops so black is actually doing fine
here
so you have to first drive the king
toward the h file and then lift the rook
up to f3
okay back to the game
so d4
bc
there was a reason that i played bc
first not just because i wanted to take
a pawn
the reason i played bc first
is because in certain positions after
knight g4 white has the move d5
to shut down the light script bishop so
i wanted to create a situation where
he is discouraged from playing d5
because
there's he takes d5 and there's bishop
takes h2 ideas
so
h3
and now i came up with this idea
of checkmating him with bishop h2 bishop
g1
so most of you were lobbying for queen
h4
as impressive as this move looks
i'm not sure it accomplishes that much
well if threatens queen takes h3
so it does threaten this very pretty
combination that's true
but unfortunately i i feel like a white
can go d5 here
white can go d5 here
shutting down the light squared bishop
so this d5 move again is a problem
and if you take then white takes
and in a position like this all of a
sudden black is losing because like
black is left with
these pieces that are just sitting there
and in the meantime the king is
uncastled and everything else is hanging
this is not good
so for that reason i wanted to keep the
queen closer to the roots of my position
and that's why we came up with queen c7
and then after 93 the whole spiel with
bishop h2 and bishop g1
threatening check made from two
different angles
the knight and the bishop both set up
the mate
i'm sure that if i research this i could
find for you
like literally a gazillion gazillion
examples of this this kind of mating
idea
in fact i will do that right now
yeah i mean here's a simple one
from a classical game actually very
strong players yanovsky
against jaffa
two two very strong players from the uh
from the 1800s
yeah so these players are playing a
match okay early 20th century
and you can see what happens here you
should you should
well you should understand that
inverting the
placement of the white queen and the
bishop increases the efficacy of that
battery but
that does not mean
that you can't use the queen bishop
battery effective in this particular
iteration here's what happens knight eg5
incredibly strong move
h6
white to play who can spot yanovsky's
sequence
and probably black was expecting him to
move the knight away
bang
bang bishop g8 and the nice flourish
here
is that black can actually defend
against mate with knight f6 but bang
knight takes f7 check bishop g8 actually
creates a a second threat
on the f7 pawn
and white just wins all the pawns and
wins the game easily
okay
so
just wanted to reinforce the notion that
this is not some sort of like
completely unknown tactical idea that
came out of nowhere it's pattern
recognition just like anything else
and and i calculated up until this point
and concluded that the position is
winning
because they're the unstoppable prospect
of g
h takes g2 and queen h2 made
and that's kind of what happened i mean
we just piled up all the pieces on him
he takes d5 is important
and this is where we'll stop king f8 to
activate the rook
put it on e8 anyway
and i feel like white is just so
completely overwhelmed here
how deep did you have to calculate this
attack in order to determine that the
king running away was okay
i would have seen king d2 and then if
thou white is fine well
i'll point out two things
the first is that black has two puns for
the piece
that might seem like a very primitive
point but what i'm trying to say is that
even if white quote-unquote consolidates
the material advantage isn't even that
big to begin with you know what i'm
saying
but the second thing i i notice is that
the king can't run away to c2 because of
the c4 idea i actually saw this when i
was playing rookie eight so that's kind
of important
and i also saw that like there's all
sorts of shenanigans here rook takes d3
bishop b5 c4
queen f4 i mean
the more ideas you see like this the
more you realize the black is just
totally winning here king c2 but c4 is
very important because without it
without it but white might be able to go
b3 and bishop b2 and then slowly somehow
white might be able to consolidate
but instead we don't let white breathe
at all
and if king b2 had happened instead of
king b1 then we would have given another
check on e5
then another double check actually no
not a double check
but the point i'm trying to make is that
we can make a second queen
and white can try to win the queen and
then bang rook takes a three check
and black wins
okay so we kind of rushed
rush through the attack but i i feel
like i explained it pretty decently
throughout the game
at the end you change your mind when
trading works instead of holding tension
why
i just felt like rookie one is more just
more clinical right if you're in time
pressure rookie one is definitely the
way to go
could weiko g3 after bishop would you
want to stop the maid threats
that's a great question
no it's illegal
it's illegal bishop that's why we wanted
to keep the bishop remember that
all the way back where i played a6 i
could sense that this bishop was going
to be important
in the opening was queen d5 instead of
knight d7
possible question by 11 years was queen
d5 yeah queen d5 is possible but then
white plays d4
that's why you rarely want to recruit
your queen to do stuff that a minor
piece could also do
because now the queen is very vulnerable
and susceptible to moves like bishop c4
it's not the end of the world because
even bishop c4 might not work due to
queen takes you to but again it all
comes back to the question like why
allow this
with that guys i'm gonna call it a day i
don't know why i even did this game
i am going to hit the sack i've got
commentary in less than four
hours this is going to be
a very very tough day um but thank you
everybody for
hanging out and the support everybody's
subscribing 100 bits thank you
thank you everybody for hanging out
appreciate the support enjoy joe veron
good night
[Music]